[Music]
first of all tell me about this amazing
look is this all you did you put this
together literally I just threw this on
can we talk about your GQ Mexico cover
because you look incredible and what I
love is what you wrote on your Instagram
that you didn't want to be retouched at
all so why was that important for you to
say um well actually when I saw the
photo like the first thing I was like oh
and then I looked at it and they're like
oh it's like no actually just let's just
leave it exactly like it is because I
don't want anybody to look at a photo of
me and think that like this is something
that they have to portray or have to be
you know because it's just ridiculous
you don't have to be me or betray
anything at all you know and I wanted to
make that a parent a one I posted that
photo so that people know that when
they're posing like that you know that
it's for more than just one reason why
was that the right time for you to strip
down and just put it all out there
I'm turning 20 in less than a week and
it just kind of felt necessary I guess
yeah I'm a little nervous
famous and let's see them - where's
Paige gonna be well there's a lot of
different things that we're gonna take
for my character this season I think
we're going to maybe watch her steer
clear both boys which would be nice but
also you know who really knows I can't
say anything I don't know anything
Marlene has told me nothing you know
when you start shooting yet ya know we
start shooting at the end of October
[Music]
you